what does school teach you about money
and the answer is nothing and that's not
a mistake it's not an accident
i knew that most people know that but
the way to keep the poor middle class
working hard is never teach them what
the rich know
einstein said
you know imagination is more important
than knowledge
but knowledge
empowers imagination
and what most people lack is real
business knowledge
like accounting you know like debt like
taxes
you got to know that stuff but they
don't teach it in school to anybody
the game the bankers and the rich play
is different than what they teach you in
school
because the school system will never
teach you about money the school system
was designed to teach you to be an
employee
which is important or a doctor or a
lawyer a specialist
but never about money well i wasn't poor
by most people's standards
but i came from a family with a poor
attitude if you know what i mean so when
i was nine years old i moved to this
rich kids school
and suddenly i realized i was poor
because it's relative and these guys
their fathers on the banks they own the
plantations they own the car dealerships
and i'm going how come my dad doesn't
own that
so i remember raising my hand when i was
nine years old talking to my fourth
grade teacher and i said you know what
am i to learn about money
and she was this woman who should have
retired 50 years earlier she was so sick
and tired of kids by this time
she says
the love of money is the root of all
evil and she says we'd all teach money
at school i said why not just go ask
your father my father was the head of
education
phd all that stuff i go home and ask him
so why don't we learn about money in
school
[Music]
and he looked at me says because the
government doesn't let us teach that
subject
the government tells us what we can
teach and what we can't teach
and i thought that was strange and i
said but
aren't we going to school to learn about
money he says no
your job is to get a job why don't you
ask your best friend's father about
money
i said why that's mike so i asked him
he says because mike's father is an
entrepreneur so i'm kid i'm all confused
but i took my dad's advice and i
trundled over to mike's father's office
and knocked on his door and i said hey
i'm here nine years old teach me about
money he says beat it kid you know but
that's what this toy refresh ted poor
dad started
and finally through persistence my rich
dad started teaching me about money on
one condition
and that condition was he would never
pay me he says the moment i pay you you
think like an employee
he says that's the trap
entrepreneurs work for free
and now i'm 9 years old my head is going
cracking in half
he says you never want a paycheck you
understand that kid said okay i got it
so i would work for free and pick up
cigarette butts and get hotels and
restaurants and i would clean and do
menial tasks and as i got older i
started getting into office work and
marketing and accounting and i was an
apprentice basically but i always work
for free
if you learn never to work for money
you'll be a rich man
most people are brainwashed when it
comes to money
go to school
get a job work hard
pay your taxes
save money get out of debt buy a house
and invest in a stock market everybody
who follows that program has been
brainwashed
because you're the sense of a person
will say i can't afford it
i can't do that
that's the problem it's up here it's
it's a real estate between this year and
that year
i can't do that
most of my family said well you i can't
afford it my father taught to say that
my mother taught me to say that my rich
dad should never say that
i also use debt i don't use money
and guys like dave ramsey said will say
live debt free and for 99 of the people
that's good advice
but if you're going to be really rich
you have to learn how to use debt as
money
never say i can't afford it my rich dad
forbid his son and me to say the words i
can't he says ask yourself how can i
how can i do it
lazy people
always say i can't afford it
i don't have the money that's why
they're poor they have a poor mindset so
instead of figuring out how to raise
money it's just really easy to be a
loser and i call losers if this is
enough
because we all have the power if we
wanted to
to not be poor if we learned how to
raise money
if you don't take risks you don't get
smarter yeah you know so you may know
the answer but you can't do anything
another mindset is i must be liked
and the other mindset is i must be
comfortable
so the people who must be liked and the
people who must be comfortable will
probably never make it
as entrepreneurs simply because you know
we hear it all the time oh
i don't really want to be rich i just
want to be comfortable
you know i want to be with all my
friends i have them like me
well they should not be entrepreneurs
they should be employees okay
focus
and what focus stands for is follow one
course until you're successful and then
keep doing it because once you find that
way of being successful you can do it
again and again and again it's just like
learning to walk you fall down a number
of times once you learn to walk you know
it forever key to success is actually
failure
acceptance school you know in school if
you make a mistake you're labeled stupid
make too many mistakes you're a failure
you know mistakes are the only way we
learn god designed us to learn by making
mistakes for example when a baby falls
down they stand back up if they don't
fall back fall down and stand back up
they never learn how to walk
and when i learned to ride a bicycle i
remember falling off the bicycle a
number of times
so after i learned to ride the bicycle i
decided to ride my bicycle to school and
guess what
i learned that failing is bad
but if i hadn't failed to fall off the
bicycle i never learned to ride a
bicycle so the reason most people in my
opinion are not successful financially
is because they went to school and they
learned that failure is bad when in
actuality
if you make a mistake and learn from
your mistakes you get smarter and richer
every time i failed it was like good
it's okay what have i learned
and the average person the reason
they're poor is they haven't failed
you know they play it so safe
they haven't made any mistakes like they
taught in school
that means they don't learn anything
that's why the school system is actually
fundamentally corrupt
it's anti-education
don't make mistakes and don't ask for
help
i encourage meditation
and this process called click clearing
you know tally talks about we have pain
bodies in our you know it's like maybe
your
father did something to you
50 years ago well that pain is still
there
and meditation doesn't get to it
so there are people with the precision
it's like a laser guided to go in there
and remove the
mental and emotional pain
so there are processes who can do that
well the more you give the more you
receive so when i meet somebody who's
not doesn't have any money it just means
they're not giving something
yeah well school teachers will never
tell you that because they don't know it
my poor dad never knew that
and he thinks they think the rich are
crooks
the ritz just played by different laws
education is more important before
but what the heck are you learning i was
called stupid so many times i almost
went nuts i flunked out of high school
twice when i was 15 and 17 because i
can't write
and today i've sold more books than most
teachers ever will it's in the millions
of books
so who was stupid